well I think you've done a really good
job of like uh just I don't ever see
your name like wrapped up in any of the
like unnecessary drama sometimes I feel
other artists I'm just like what's going
on why is this like these people have no
reason to have problems with each other
like it just doesn't make sense so it's
good to see like you're I feel like you
you're kind of also like very mature
like you're like you're like a young OG
you know what I mean like you you've
you've seen this game from a lot of
different areas with me I'm more like if
it's really like if you if it's really
like some type of pressure you you have
to like address me like for real or you
have to like address me in real life
like
people see me outside I'm outside
everywhere I'm everywhere I'm at every
Festival I'm at every show so I don't
really feel that energy from anybody
like you know and I don't really give
that energy like I don't have you don't
you give a number positive energy yeah
like I'm so confident and so happy
with what I'm doing that I don't have
really the time to like nitpick girls
for no reason right you know but um yeah
like I'm a positive person for the most
part everybody that knows me knows I
just like to have a good time and spread
love is Russ on the album
not not right now but I'm trying to find
a song for him we were speaking about
that the other day I'm trying to find
like the perfect song Because I Love
Russ he's like one of the most
knowledgeable and talented people and
he's like a like he's like really tell
he I think he yesterday he was teasing
he's gonna put out like a 70s rock song
and I was like bro I bet it's gonna be
fire because he can do everything
he's a beast for sure you've done some
huge festivals like I feel like you've
done them all at this point but like
what was the one Festival you did where
you just looked at the crowd you were
like [__] this is [__] crazy the
biggest one ever yeah or just like or
maybe a nervous moment or just like a
like something that just sticks out
you're the biggest uh out to this day
the biggest Festival I've ever done was
the Telethon and Chile with J Balvin wow
it was 75 000 people it was so many
people that I couldn't even see
like physical people all I could see was
little dots like little heads little
flashes of Lights crazy but that was the
most I've ever seen
um most people ever but but I love just
like Festival crowds because people that
go to festivals like they're going there
they won't have to rage yes yeah so
that's my favorite my favorite energy
because there's like and then you go to
a nightclub and it's like there's people
in there just like they're holding their
bottles standing in the [__] booths
and they're just like looking at you
like don't get me wrong I love
nightclubs too now no they're great like
I turn the nightclubs up I just opened a
nightclub so yes
I come pop in yeah we can book in
Wisconsin I love Arizona too yeah it
gets wild in Scottsdale it does it does
get wild you don't know it gets wild so
you go there and see it for yourself
this is true this is true for you uh
what about going out on tour for your
fans like going and kind of just
touching your direct fan base with a
tour is that something that's coming
with this album yes yes I'm so glad you
asked that because I've never been on my
own tour I didn't say I feel like it
hasn't happened because I'm sure because
of the pandemic never and I'm such like
an like he's like an older OG artist I'm
not I've got on my own tour
um but I've always been on tour with
like huge acts so I feel like it takes
up when you go on tour it takes up
months yeah so like you'll go on tour
and you get off tour you start recording
you go on tour again
um and I think that that's just helps me
anyways because when it comes time that
I go on tour there's gonna be like so
many more people for me to see
um and it's like they're there for you
yeah I can't wait to see what my tour
looks like like what my fans singing
album Cuts you got the merch booming you
know what I'm saying I'm excited for
that so album coming soon really soon
very soon very very soon yeah I don't
like to talk about it I like to be about
it you know so one day we'll just be
like oh the B album's coming out in two
weeks yeah
uh the new record is crazy with
Timberland thank you
um
is there a new single coming yeah
um you know me it's always a new single
coming actually now I've been way more
consistent because like I've been
learning to find that balance like when
you doing so many shows I feel like this
is like new territory for me like I've
the past two years I've been the busiest
I've ever been in my life so I've been
trying to balance like you know
new shows new music seeing family having
a social life all those things is so
hard to do I wonder like when because
I've I've seen artists who will do all
these festivals right and like
they're not doing the the shows we just
talked about like when you do your own
tour does that ever affect the way you
create like have you ever like been like
damn I gotta make a [__] Festival
record because I see a lot of guys doing
that [__] like and sometimes it can it
can kind of work out in the negative
because I think when you try to do stuff
on purpose sometimes it comes across
that way
um yeah you know well I do so many
festivals and so many like it's like
like just
shows with high energy so a lot of my
records when I go to the studio are high
energy records because I'm always
picturing myself performing records on
stage but I do have those album Cuts
Like motionless where it's like wait on
16 that's like way more vulnerable where
like I try to you know
talk my [__] but still
still give a Vibe you know
um for me it's like I like to get into
so many different beats like whatever
the beat calls for is what I'm gonna
give
what is uh bia's go-to show to binge
watch right now